hey everybody its Jesse and happy Monday
I hope everyone had a good weekend
I had a nice break from coding this
weekend so I don't I don't think I did
any coding at all except I help my wife
with with some coding so she's doing she
just started freaking camp so but other
than that I had had a good break
my oldest daughter just turned six what
she's gonna turn six in a few days but
we had her party on on Sunday so I'm all
rested up and today I've been working on
adding some security to our file uploads
so the first thing I was trying to do
was just to add a whitelist for file
types so it's pretty predictable what
gets uploaded I already can see what
what everyone is uploaded over the last
year I guess so I think it why twist
would probably be the best way to go and
I could probably add in some more things
after that like limit the file size the
number of files but when I was trying to
do that I did all this research to try
to figure out the best way to do it and
then I couldn't get the server so we had
one version of this site that was
running on port 9000 and I couldn't get
it to work and so now I'm going back
through pool requests to see what has
changed since the last time that I had
that working so I'll show you what kind
of errors I'm getting and see maybe
maybe one of you
have had a similar area before and can
point me in the right direction here hey
everyone I just check the live chat
how's it going
Ike so the the editor is actually Adam
so it's the Adam editor from github with
the SETI theme alright so let me show
you the errors so this is what I'm
getting I'll make it a little bigger I'm
getting these errors I have there are
some things on Stack Overflow and an
issue on the create react app github
repo that's people are having similar
errors so I'm I'm just trying to
troubleshoot that see the stream is
started right in the middle of me doing
the troubleshooting this is what I found
so oops
Thanks so someone had had a similar
issue and after going back and forth a
bit trying to figure out what the issue
was this fixed it for them so in their
package JSON they had their home page
listed and I thought hey we did ever
homepage changed it at one point so you
could see on our package JSON we
actually we have this as the home page
and that was to get github pages working
so I thought okay maybe it's that so I
took out the home page and that didn't
fix it I tried adding the home page in
here like like it's been done here and
that didn't work so now my my next
my next idea is have a basically I just
want to see what all has changed can I
just take out some things and test it so
I'm looking back into I guess this was
the commit let me bring this over this
is the commit where we added github
pages support and so the only file
changed basically is a package.json so
it it shouldn't make a difference that
we have these dependencies that all the
only thing that change that would
actually make any difference at all
would be this home page thing and if we
change yet this should be fine yeah
hmm
yeah so I'm kind of at a point where I
guess I need to do some more research
some I'm a little bit stuck here so
unless someone has some ideas I probably
just switch back to the main branch so I
luckily wood started doing this on
another branch because I well for number
one it's good practice to do new things
on another branch but I suspected that I
might have something like this happened
where I get stuck and so I'm just going
to switch back to the master branch and
work on some other stuff because for the
live stream me reading through github
issues is not going to be very exciting
not not that my streams are supposed to
be exciting or arcs I think that but
it's definitely don't want to watch me
read so the movies over in my other
screen and work on them later and let's
pull over this
so you can see it's on the branch file
type check and I should probably push
that to github in case anyone wants to
look at it so okay that's good that's
what should be changed so I'm just
committing this I'm adding the files and
I'm committing it to our git repo and
I'm at a commit message basically all I
did was install a package called file
type that reads a stream of your file
coming in and it reached enough of it to
give you the the file type and that was
about as far as I got and I set up in
the server JS file just a console log
the file type just a test to make sure
it was working and at that point that's
when I realized that I needed to fix
whatever was going on with with the
server not being able to run okay so
let's go
there we go so now that's on github you
can check out the little bit that I did
do if you like and now we're back on the
master branch so we should be able to
just continue on and do some other
things and then come back to that later
on after I do similar research I'm gonna
bring over my Pomodoro timer and okay
cool so Patrick is testing this so
thanks Patrick I I appreciate it all
right so I'm going to start my timer and
do some stuff I'm going to start the
timer we'll check my Trello board and
see what we can do
okay so actually I think that's it guys
spent for Pomodoro sessions on this
today already
alright so let's see what we need but
okay let's do this
because this will let me this would be a
good way to introduce some of the
changes from last pull request as well
so Matt submitted a pull request with
some good stuff in it it was pull
request 52 if you want to check out
everything to change some of the things
that changed include using so setting
state outside of the constructor we had
a big kind of discussion and talking
about what will the best practices were
for that and so basically the conclusion
is that it's okay to do that it's
syntactic sugar you need you definitely
need Babel which if you're writing stuff
with reactive you're running that anyway
so you just need to be able to have so
this is we're talking about just setting
state like this at least initially right
you're we're still going to use set
state you know anywhere down here you
know which is what you should do but at
least initially instead of doing the
constructor we can do it like this
so almost everywhere this is in change
back to using this method which is you
know a bit shorter a little bit cleaner
something I can't remember all the other
changes as well but that was one of the
main changes was to change these back
and also the other one of the other big
changes and the one that we're going to
work on right now
on kind of improving even more is this
this card so what Matt had done so what
I had done previously was I wrapped this
card in the paper component and I gave
it a Z depth so in material UI you give
you can give an item a paper component
depth
what I mean by depth in case you're not
familiar with how this works in material
design is let me pull this over
something like this okay so on the
posters page you can see each one of
these cards has you know an apparent
depth because of the shadow and then
when I hover over it the depth changes
or it changes apparently it seems as if
the hovered card is closer than these
other cars so that's what I mean by Z
depth as in like the Z coordinate for
talking like X Y Z so this is how you
set the depth on the paper component so
you can't do Z depth on card that's why
I wrapped it in paper so I took away the
black shadow from the card so I wouldn't
have double shadows wrapped it in the
paper component set the Z depth and I
was checking for when the the mouse was
going in and out and I was changing the
state so the state in of death and
[Applause]
actually this isn't the new stuff
actually this isn't bad Elvises right
now because this will show you what we
were doing and now it's changed so you
can see I was just changing it from
depth 1 to depth 2 but there were some
some weird stuff going on it wasn't
exactly the what I wanted so I'm not
sure why they didn't update sometimes
when I pull things and it doesn't auto
update and Adam I have to close it and
open it again so let's try that
hmm
okay it looks like it looks like Matt
didn't remove these possibly we you know
maybe he wasn't sure if I wanted to keep
these to go back to it so he did remove
the onmouseover and onmouseout from the
actual component so it used to be on
this paper component here okay so that's
nice it is kind of nice though that we
can see his side by side so instead of
doing this Matt made a a clasp and what
did he put this I think he put it on in
the poster CSS file of the sass file
yeah okay so he just uses CSS hover and
he added that on on to this div so he
wrapped everything in another div gave
it a height of 100 percent and then is
adding this this class name of
yes it fix hey you see
sorry I'm just checking this alliant
yeah the fixed site just does the 100%
height so basically what I want to do
now is I think we can remove this paper
element we can probably remove this div
and just apply the styles directly to
the card we may need to keep one Dev
actually but we for sure we can remove
the paper so I'm gonna go ahead and
remove the paper now because we will not
need that so let's remove that and we
can get rid of paper here
and now we can check this out just to
verify I thought we could remove a paper
telling you know I know what's happening
okay so that the paper was where we were
getting the initial state from which is
fine we don't need that because we could
just take this off of the card
we take that off the card and the card
we need to add the
we can add fixed side
yeah
okay so that gives us
pretty much the same effect but it's not
it's not exactly what I want so let me
pull in so hopefully you'll be able to
see the comparison so this is on
materialized and this is how their
effect works and we'll compare that to
what's going on here so there's
definitely a difference there's a
difference in the shadow and and it
seems in the transition it seems like
the transition is just slightly slower
here the shadow is longer not quite as
dark this one is shorter and more dark
so I want to switch this to use the
shadow you know more like this on hover
and so as far as I know materialised
doesn't have just a class a hover class
or I'm sorry material UI doesn't have
just a hover class it's possible that I
missed it but in looking through the
documentation for cards
there wasn't an option just to make the
card hover Abul so in materialise there
is so I'm just gonna import the styles
from materialized and apply them to
these cars
okay
alright so I just checked the live chat
quickly and have some more info about
the air ok thanks so matt matt has some
input as well
so patrick it was working on port 3000
it was port 9000 that I couldn't get it
just came up with a blank page and had
some errors
all right so let's just change change
the hover a bit and possibly see if we
can even get rid of this this other div
and just slim things down just a bit
so what I was thinking
initially was I could just get rid of
this and set the styles set the styles
for the box shadow it's a nun like I had
before the problem is I'd have to use
I'd either have to do it in line in that
case anything I do here one wouldn't
work it would get canceled out by this
or I could do here and then put
important which I'm gonna try to do but
I vaguely remember trying this before
and if you're using important the hover
style just got automatically applied it
was kind of odd I'm gonna try it again
but maybe I'm remembering wrong and
it'll work but that's the plan so
basically we're going to use this hub
herbal class but we're going to bring in
the base card shadow from materialize
and also the transition so basically
everything that they use in materialize
for their card hover we're going to
bring that in as well and we're just
going to try to override what's going on
here
so I think I have the the code from
material as yep since we've been
borrowing so heavily from materialize I
just leave their repo open
okay just not in this one just get back
to components I don't remember which one
I was on before their evils okay we'll
try out cards
okay z-depth which ice I figured z-depth
would be in variables but maybe it has
its own no it doesn't
this will try again maybe I know it's
not there
it's probably in global there we go
okay so we want to grab this I guess
I'll just grab the whole thing like
since we're using sass anyway we'll put
it in that format okay
and the initial card
zyne up for one okay
okay and I don't think I don't think we
need this extend
we'll see we'll leave it in for now
Susie that's one and
all right so we need to put in let's try
it
we'll try taking this out first like I
said I hopefully we can make it work
like that and then it would just make
the component a bit smaller let's see
where's my clothes I'm not sure what
classes I'm already passing in
hmm
I guess I'm not I don't think I'm even
using this anywhere to have the classes
here
oh wow
can you check
I'm gonna check my time okay we have
five minutes so five minutes I'm gonna
go to the to the live chat and catch up
on everything that's going on so if here
so if you ask me questions or anything
I'm not I'm not ignoring you at least
forever okay well let me check just to
make sure okay
so good so far let's let's give this
these for testing let's just call this
card oops
and hopefully my doing let's give it a
see dad one and
actually
classes however so let's go
actually how do I add what's the best
way to add in classes that I'm
hard-coding but then also be able to put
in some classes as well so obviously I
need this classes but then I want to add
in these can I
I don't think I can do that we'll just
we'll see find out all right I didn't do
what I wanted it to do but let's see
what classes end up on here
undefined card see there's one okay
okay so Matson use template literal
syntax okay cool
I like template little syntax anyway
yeah oops
so I know we've gone over template
literal syntax a bunch of times but in
case you didn't see any of that or you
know you're not familiar with it let's
let me just explain it since it is it's
not like old-school JavaScript I guess
so this is not es5 this is es6 stuff so
when we use backticks instead of double
quotes of single quotes this is a string
that you can do JavaScript inside of so
if you want to do JavaScript you just
put dollar sign curly bracket and then
anything inside these brackets is
treated as JavaScript so we this classes
is not a string it's a variable so it'll
pool in whatever the value of classes is
and then everything else is to string
other cool things we can do with there
like like this works you can have spaces
and stuff in between so really cool very
useful way better than having to put a
bunch of plus signs and lots of quotes
so anyway thanks Matt so this should say
yeah so now this is spaced out although
it does say undefined and I don't want
it to say undefined so what am I doing
wrong
oh I never changed that wait no I don't
need to change that what am I thinking
yeah so I'm pulling in should be pulling
in classes
oh well my timers up so let me take five
minutes and go through the live chat not
a whole lot in the live chat yet so
shouldn't take too long may not even use
up the whole five minutes so you have
air drifters hi from San Diego awesome
welcome and thanks for joining in in the
live chat
okay so update on the port 9000 err so
Patrick was able to recreate that error
yes it's a cryptic error yeah the error
just doesn't it's not super helpful okay
well at least I guess I feel better that
you can duplicate the air and it's not
just something on my machine
Sebastian Xavier says I think coding is
cool I just started learning HTML and a
little bit of JavaScript
I took a week-long class too that's
awesome
and welcome to coding yeah so hopefully
you're you're able to follow at least
some of what we're doing so I know now
if you just you know you're doing a
little bit of JavaScript you may not
know figure out you know everything
that's going on here but little things
like template literal syntax that'll be
kind of a cool some cool syntax that
will save you some time that you might
not get in maybe like beginning
JavaScript courses
okay so Matt's given some advice as well
on this
okay so did I have
so I guess I was before classy
anyway
cool okay it's a Sebastian's a versus I
know the basics yeah so anyway so
hopefully it's you can you can follow
along with some of it depending on what
I'm doing for you know for one of these
it may be more beginner friendly you
know we just do we would own everything
we need to do to build you know a whole
site so some of them will be really
basic and some streams will be a little
bit more advanced
all right so I am through with
everything in the live chat for now
early which that's crazy normally I
always go over and so I am going to set
my reset my timer to twenty five minutes
so I'm gonna do at least one more twenty
five minute session and then we'll see
how much is in the live chat I don't
think I'm gonna do a third one we'll see
I do want to make sure that I get out of
here and enough time to take my son to
his karate class so may wrap things up a
bit earlier
we'll still definitely have an hour-long
stream today though
all right so on my other screen I'm
gonna bring up I'm gonna bring up what
that generic card component was since
I've changed it and I don't I don't want
to undo everything just to see what I
would I change so
because I think I changed some stuff
that I shouldn't and that's why I'm
having some problems
okay so I actually did have
hmm
so initially I think it was like this
and that's where I was pulling it in so
I never really needed to change these
well I guess I guess it didn't really
matter so but originally on the
outermost div this is what was being
pulled in I always did have classes here
to just pass down the classes right to
the card component but this makes sense
to do it like this so let's see
all right cool so now we are getting
hoverball which is what we want cards
you have okay great so now let's make
this work why isn't this working what
did I do
alright so I'm gonna try this with this
is gonna look terrible the first
so I'm just gonna confirm that this is
working yet okay
I was great know how
let's see if this works yep all right
great so whatever I was worried about at
the beginning I don't know what I was
thinking but this definitely does work
great
all right so now we can see it's
definitely a different a different
effect okay so I I wanted to switch it
up to this for for a few reasons mainly
because this is consistent with what
I've been doing with all my other sites
so while I do want to use material UI
for react sites going forward maybe
probably I'll use the newest version for
the next site I do but I I do want the
styles to match because you know we have
some sites that it's going to be a while
before they get redone so I do want to
keep it consistent so in little details
like this it's not really a big deal
especially since there's not built in
hover mechanism I think it's okay to go
with materialise and the way they do it
all right but I think that's it it looks
more smooth I kind of like how the
shadows a bit more spread out I'm not so
I don't know it just seemed abrupt I
guess that it was so dark underneath
here so anyway that that works so I'd
say that that was best-case scenario
here so you know over here we added in a
bit more CSS but the component itself
we're able to get rid of four lines in
this component so it's not bad also we
can remove this because we're no longer
we no longer need to use that because
that was here so that's five lines and
we got rid of our import for paper it's
a sick
lines so we remove six lines that's cool
so six lines from that component and
we've imported this now what I'd like to
do is have this in a different file
right because I'm not just going to use
this for posters so I think we should
actually all of this should be should be
used so I think I'm just gonna take all
of this and I'm gonna put it in
something that gets loaded up a bit
higher so maybe you're in our app yeah
so these are more I guess like utility
classes so like this this video line you
know so I'm gonna move that up here I
think it makes more sense to be here
since cards are so common in material
design and we use cards on a lot of
different pages
oops okay so for right now at least you
don't have anything in posters so let's
see I I don't know that I will add
anything any special styles and posters
so I may just get rid of this file
completely
let's get rid of these and then let's
get rid of it
oops now I wasn't importing it there I
was importing it in posters actually now
that I think about it since some of what
we're doing applies to the flight of
cards I guess it doesn't apply to just
cards so we could add potentially we can
add hover ball as a class to anything
and make it horrible so I'm for a second
I thought about making some a SAS file
for this generic card component and
moving the styles into that but now I'm
I'm gonna leave it where it is I don't I
can't think of anything right now that I
would use hover go on but at least in
materialize it is separate and you can
use it on more than just cards so I'll
leave it as is for now and that'll keep
us from making more more files so all
right so now all told we've removed
seven lines of code between the two of
these components we've removed two files
we have added a bit on to our app dot s
CSS file so
let's say not bad I'm happy with that
result and that took while way less than
anticipated so it's great so what was
that I'm gonna say 1.5 so I guess not
way less I forgotten I'd already done
one Pomodoro psycho on this before okay
but still under the amount of time that
I expected so while we're on this
generic card we may as well go to the
home page and add that to some of the
home cards so these two kind of go
together so we'll work on both of these
I'm gonna move this over here until I
get some more ideas about it mmm not I'm
not gonna try to add the icons right now
I'm still not exactly sure how I want to
do that okay so let's go to the home
page I'm gonna move this over here and
do this
okay so here's our our home view and
here's where we're bringing in our
generic cards and we want to instead of
doing it like this we want to do it more
like this so we want to bring in hover
Balazs well actually in link writes have
horrible and link and actually let me
show you the home page in case you
haven't seen it before
so here's our home page right now so you
see we don't have hover over any of
these I'm clicking on all of them and
they're not linked ship but they all
need to link to something so some of
them are actually going to go they're
just going to be a file download so the
PowerPoint will be the brand manual will
be but then these four will link to
other places other views within this
site and and this is at is not the final
version of this page I realized it's
very plain looking I guess
so we need to go to where the data is so
this is kind of really nice how this is
set up is because this is all pulling in
data and then everything's set up kind
of as props to do different things in
this component converting these cards
over is going to be really easy we just
need to change things in the way the
data is set up and pulled in which is
really cool that was our goal from the
beginning with this generic card
component was something that could do
anything you would want a card to do I
mean within reason just by passing in
different props alright so let me see
let's find our data and we want to pull
our poster data up here and
links data yep this is it okay so we
just need to add huh verbal true.really
to everything so
hmm
actually these already say linked to
so that's all right I suppose if we just
changed this to link that we should be
fine oh you know what
I'm sorry these are the side nav side
nav links so sorry if you hear that
noise it's my phone going off I don't
recognize the number I'm not going to
answer it but it's sound vibrated there
we go that's what we want okay yeah so
let's pull in huh verbal and also like
audible both of these in now just to get
him in there
I guess so I'm gonna put them on the
bottom
okay
let's let's pull up that links data
again because we can use a lot of this
request
shares story
this isn't just posters this will be
logos logos posters what did I name that
page
those posters
I think that's what I had it as manual
and then the other two I'll just leave
like this for now I'm not sure where
those files are actually gonna be so
when I find that out I can just put the
data in whoops
okay
hmm
okay what am I not bringing in
oh I forgot to actually pass those props
okay so car title
there we go
that works great let's see I do want to
check alright great so that is did we
never make this view I guess we didn't I
thought I had me put in the content for
all the views but I guess I missed one
so I'll make that one yeah this one's
really easy it's just two cards
okay actually kind of don't like that
you have to click this and then click
another spot to go in there
it would it would be nicer if maybe I
just had logos posters and you could
click to go under one of the other and
then it wouldn't match the rest of the
cards unless I had other things down
here
I'm not sure let me know what you think
it's one extra click and I guess I do
get the chance to put more information
about the logos and the posters on the
second page the only reason I combined
them was because I just I didn't want
one extra hanging down here but I guess
we do have
we have the tutorial if I can think of
one more thing to put here the glossary
I guess then we could have nine that
might work let me know what you think
about that would it be too much instead
of six to have nine of them split out
logos and posters have the tutorial
visible right away and have the glossary
visible
yeah that might work and before when I
had these large icons that would have
been too much but now it will definitely
fit and I'll make the page look a bit
less dull okay all right see about three
and a half minutes left for this
Pomodoro session since we finished that
so this was I guess the the smallest I
can put in is a half so I'll put in a
half for both of these but really it
took less than a half of a session if
you're not familiar with Pomodoro
sessions and things this is just a way
of breaking up your time of working and
estimating what you do so you take a
five-minute break every 25 minutes after
four sessions a ten-minute break there
may be other ways to do that that's just
the way that I learned and the the
estimation comes in where you try to
estimate beforehand how many Pomodoro
sessions it will take to do something
and then after you do it you put how
many it actually did take then you can
get a good idea of whether you know how
long projects will take after you do it
for a while you get pretty good at
estimating so right now I'm you know
these numbers are pretty close when I
first started doing it my numbers would
be very different I usually would
overestimate now I'm a lot better at
that and that's really good
it's good for time management personally
but it's also good if you're freelancing
to give have an accurate idea of how
long projects will take so that you can
figure out pricing so very very helpful
it's been very helpful for me to keep me
on track I've been doing this system for
over a year now
alright oops and I meant to look at
another thing I don't know I get
anything else done in three minutes it's
probably two and a half by now oops
actually we can clean this up a bit so
Matt already did this so I'm gonna just
put that and done since I have no idea
how long it took Matt and I am NOT I
really I don't want to require
contributors to check their time as well
anything done in a pull request I'm just
gonna pull over and put nothing there so
that way I'll know if I see something
like this immediately they all know I
didn't do this this was from full
request okay not bad getting through a
lot of to do's I know this list isn't
complete I'm sure there'll be other
things I'll see to add to this but not
bad we cut this about in half from what
it was earlier in the day okay
let me
so it's just regular get add get commit
just like we did earlier so as soon as
that finishes I'm going to push this to
github so that you all have access to
everything that we just did make sure
there was one other thing that I think
we could take out now so I'm pretty sure
pretty sure we're not using horrible
anymore
yeah we're I think we're not using hub
herbal and since we're not using all
this I'll probably remove all this let's
just remove this right now
so I don't forget so you don't need
hover bowl and we don't need it was it
in posters so we don't need it here
and we don't need any of this
and since we don't need that we don't
need debounce or we're getting rid of
you in more lines it's just great we
don't need this oops
actually do we need any of this now I
don't think so
I'm scared of this
I just saw Blake said his fan is loud I
actually don't have my fan on right now
maybe my computer is lovin yeah for some
reason I didn't notice it cuz I had
music playing in my headphones but yeah
my computer is a bit louder than normal
it's normally pretty quiet let's see
I think that's all we can remove but
that's pretty good and we can also
that's all I'm gonna do right now I'm
thinking can we change this into
functional component probably all right
so Oh
and I just changed this hold on
so let me go to the live chat and see
what's going on if you aren't familiar
with how this stream goes the end of the
stream is saved for question and answers
so we have a little intro some coding
and then question answer Wow I messed
something up
let's and then the that we do some code
and then the last part is question
answer so if you don't want to stick
around for the question and answer
session then thanks for watching and
I'll be back tomorrow hopefully you can
join in again otherwise please put your
questions in the live chat now and I'll
just go straight from the top of the
live chat and go through all the
questions try to answer as many as I can
if you can't stick around to hear your
question answered you can always catch
the recording of this that's available
on free code camp or you could just ask
me some other way like on Twitter or any
social media network where you can find
me interrupted depth of thumb okay I
must not have gotten rid of everything
actually yeah we did have depth we were
using the z-depth in here what we
hmm
all right but I think we can get rid of
this safely without without needing it
so let's let's see
okay so that those still work great so
hopefully if anyone notices any bugs
with that because of how much was
changed I mean I certainly didn't test
it thoroughly but everything should work
and all right so let's see what it says
now
so while that's running I'm gonna try to
find some questions
Chris Chung says can I do this on a
Chromebook you certainly could do this
on a Chromebook you would have to use
some type of cloud editor like cloud
nine I can't remember I've used some
other ones before but I can't remember
the name so if you check out I think the
website c9 dot IO that would work
basically you just need an environment
where you can run well you can run all
the stuff that you need to run so you
need to be able to bring in NPM packages
and things like that so cloud 9 can do
that and there are alternatives so I I
have developed on a Chromebook before
and it works basically in the same way
as long as you only have a good cloud
development environment I say it says
can you get a job with just knowing
front-end yeah yeah for sure so I mean
I'm a front-end developer right now I do
know a little bit more than front-end I
do have to do some back-end stuff and
DevOps stuff from time to time because
we don't have other people to do that
here but there are plenty of jobs for
front-end developers if you check out
Stack Overflow jobs you'll see a lot or
really any any job get github as their
own job thing but I see it son of
front-end jobs on Stack Overflow pretty
much every time I'm on there it shows me
front-end jobs
Patrick I see you told me not to forget
the commas I knew someone had you have
seen that in the live chat wants us
Andrea says great when I'm watching this
video I can study coding and learn
English at the same time well that's
that's awesome I had never thought that
someone could learn English while
watching this but that's cool glad I can
help in any way
Rohan says late yet again well at least
you made it before it was over this time
yang John says hi hey how's it going
thanks for watching John Henson says
Jessie yes
add more to that dole page yeah for sure
okay Blake sorry Blake Blake had said
that my fan was loud and I commented on
a few minutes ago thinking that he meant
my my office fan which I did I was
running you know when it got really hot
in here earlier in the summer but he
actually did meet my computer fan so
sorry about that and actually quieted
down huh I can't hear it at all so I
don't know what was going on I mean you
all saw what I was going it's not like I
had anything open or closed it but
whatever occasionally my computer has
just been like the fan just kicks into
high gear and it's just super loud for a
few minutes and then it's okay Blake
says c9i Oh does require credit card but
it's refundable and it's either zero a
$1 charge said he did it the other day
and it was not a problem at all yeah
that's true I always forget that when I
started cloud 9 they didn't require a
credit card but then they changed their
policy afterwards and you do need a
credit card to sign up even if you're
just going there
plan they just wanted I did continent
get I like kind of I kind of think
cloud9 got bought out by somebody and
then the policy switch but I can't
remember exactly what would happen with
that J Evans asked hey Jesse what was
your time management solution again okay
yeah I'll go over this time management
solution so basically it's it's a
Pomodoro Technique and so I have this
Pomodoro timer so it's a 25-minute
session five-minute breaks every four
sessions I take a long break of ten
minutes okay so that's the time this is
just tomato timer calm that's tomato -
timer calm there's so many Pomodoro
timers out there and in fact I think I
think it's one of the lessons in free
code camp to make your own Pomodoro
timer so I'm sure there are thousands it
probably tens of thousands of Pomodoro
timers available out there but that use
that for my timer and then I have this
is just Trello and it's a free project
management solution and I set things up
like like this it doesn't come set up
like this automatically so but I so I
create these these cards these columns
of to do ready for development in
progress testing done and wish list
wishlist is just stuff that I'd like to
have that isn't necessary to complete
the project but if I get time I'll put
them in the other ones are pretty
self-explanatory so when I go to create
a new task I try to break the tasks down
as small as possible and
I create the task and then I add a
number and that number is how many
Pomodoro sessions so how many 25-minute
sessions I think it will take me to
complete this now that there are other
ways of doing this some people I've I've
heard some people do like complexity so
the number doesn't represent time it
represents complexity so I'm not to that
point yet maybe I'll switch over to
something like that but for now this
this works for me now after I complete
this I would actually put how many
points it took so let's say it only took
me three I have three in there so now
these two numbers get compared so if I
were to move this over here you can see
it tells me you know five was what I
estimated and three is what it really
was and you can see it just adds that up
on the top so I can see very quickly
since it's still in progress this means
I'm not done so if I look at this I
would say okay I need about three more
sessions to go until I'm done with this
column I can you know I can look in here
and say okay five more sessions I'm done
with my entire project assuming that I
already had laid out all the two dues
and then at the end I can look and say
it took me this many sessions to
complete or this many sessions to
complete so it was either I was ahead of
schedule either overestimate or
underestimated but I can tell all of
that and on my next project I can go
back in and check and say okay well this
took me this long last time so I would
have a good idea how long it's going to
take me the next time so that's how I do
it it's um it's been pretty useful you
definitely have to be consistent with it
for it to be useful but I found that the
the five minute breaks are really nice
because sometimes it's easy like if you
have these for me when I have a problem
I'm working on like a bug
or something and I can't get it to work
I just get so into it you all get buried
and documentation and trying to search
through things and it's easy for me to
waste you know hours trying to look into
this but if I take that five minute
break it just forces me to take a step
back and say look back at my Trello
Trello board mark another Pomodoro
session and then I can see the big
picture again and at that little bit of
time that few minutes allows me to just
think okay is this super-important can I
just switch to something else and get
something done and then come back to
that when I have a better idea of of
what I want to do and sometimes that's
that's the best thing to do at the time
I switch it up I get some stuff done I
feel a little bit accomplished and then
later on some idea comes to me that I
can try so instead of just spinning my
wheels or not getting anything done I'm
way more productive so it doesn't always
work out like that but it's happened
enough that you know this has definitely
been worth it for me and very useful so
anyway hopefully that was a decent
enough explanation there is a I learned
this in a course on Pluralsight so I had
like a free three-month subscription to
Pluralsight at one time and there was a
course on I think the course was called
agile for one so it was talking about
agile technique but in in that course it
was talking about the Pomodoro Technique
and Kanban boards which this is actually
I not Pomodoro this is Kanban so anyway
it was combining several different
techniques and trying to adapt it so
that someone who's not on a team could
work in a way that's closer to how agile
teams work I mean you can't replicate it
with one person but it it definitely
helped me like I said I've been using it
for over a year now and definitely liked
it a little bit more work to set up at
the beginning but it's nice
I let's see let me get there's a few
more comments here almost to the bottom
oh sorry
Jay had a follow-up question about the
number system for Trello that yes so
that's actually a chrome add-on called
scrum for Trello yeah I'm pretty sure
that's the name of it let me check I'm
gonna check my extensions I say my
chrome ascent extension is quickly to
let you know the name of this for sure
yeah it's called scrum for Trello so
it's not a Trello thing that you get in
Trello it's a chrome add-on which is
kind of cool because the Trello add-ons
I think you can have one now for free
but if you want any more than that you
have to pay so it doesn't use up one of
your your Trello add-on slows alright so
John Hanson says a component that
imports multiple components and two
components imported array data comes
from two sources can't see how to make
the array get mapped from a variable so
I can reuse the components okay let me
read this again all right so I'm gonna
read this to myself
all right so you have one component
that's importing multiple components all
right so that's that's fine so in two
components imported array data comes
from two sources can't see how to make
the array get mapped from a variable so
I can reuse the components
okay so I guess it would be easier if I
could see the code so if you do have
this on github or something that would
be that would be cool but I would check
out I know that we're using we're
mapping over a lot of data in this this
project we're doing it and then the last
project we're doing it maybe if you
check out some of the the views where
we're importing different components and
different data I know especially in the
last project we we were importing well I
guess we we ended up importing it
combining it into one one array but I
want to check that out and see if it
helps if not and you if you can send me
a link I oh I check it out and let you
know what I think about it maybe I can
help but anyway I mean you should be
able to use map and go over unless I'm
misunderstanding what's going on you
should be able to you know have that
array you know as a variable and just do
dot map something like something like
this right so array variable map and
then you could just put data and then
after that you could have like h1
I mean you get at something like this
where I mean I guess we could do it more
like right so you could map over that
data and so this component you would be
able to reuse this component as much as
you want as long as you have that data
available in this parent component so
not sure if that's if that's helpful I
said I could be misunderstanding what's
going on but let me know send me the
code if you can
okay so John said I just want to import
a different array for different views
using the same components yet you should
be able to where are you importing the
arrays from so are you making API calls
or do these arrays exist like like how
we have them in these data files
because I guess that essentially that's
kind of what we're doing right so you
know so we're importing an array called
poster data into posters jas and then
we're using the card component we're
mapping over the card component and then
you know in home DJ s we're importing an
array called generic card data and then
we're mapping over that data and we're
reusing the generic card component there
okay
mattias what are you doing if you mean
the project this is a react project that
would create react app and it's
basically just a way for people at where
I work to submit requests to my
department through this react site so it
takes file filled input file uploads and
it forwards that on to a project
management system it does a few other
things but that's the main purpose of it
if you meant what was I doing at the
time you asked that I was explaining my
approach my time management system right
at that moment Patrick I just saw that
you gave J the name scrum for Trello so
thanks for that sorry I didn't see that
earlier
okay so Patrick says that John could
pass in a boolean flag to decide which
data to grab and pass that in as a prop
yeah
or Patrick says if you have more than
two types you can pass a type prop so
that could work I guess each I don't
know I really would actually like to see
that so I think this is probably the
type of thing that if I or someone else
in the live chat can see the code you'd
probably be able to figure it out
a lot more quickly so so anyway if
possible I think we can get it sorted
out if we could see it but I've come to
the end of the live chat so I think I'm
gonna wrap things up now thank you so
much for for watching and for all your
help especially for those of you who
submitted pull requests help me out in
the live chat tested things really
appreciate that I appreciate everybody
watching everybody ask questions I love
to get questions and it's really cool if
I could help you out in some way I will
be back tomorrow I think that should be
the same time as normal I don't think I
have anything conflicting so 2 p.m.
Eastern Time and hopefully I can get
whatever's going on with that server
sorted out so that we can go over some
file uploads security with nodejs
I think that would be cool to do on a
stream but until then thanks for
watching and have a great day